DON'T HIT
THE MAIDEN SLAYER.
THAT'S WHAT I'M CALLING
MY FACE NOW--THE MAIDEN SLAYER.
- HEY, DON'T WORRY.
I PLAYED A LOT OF AREA 51.
HERE WE GO.
[knock on door]
- UH, GUYS...
WE HAVE COMPANY.
- OH, FUDGE.
- OH...YOU TWO ARE HERE.
AND A HOMELESS PERSON.
OKAY, GAYLE, THESE ARE JUST
A COUPLE MORE EMPLOYEES OF MINE.
ALL RIGHT,
SO WHERE'S THIS ACID?
- WHAT?
YEAH, WHERE'S THE ACID?
THAT'S A TRICK QUESTION.
IT'S PROBABLY
AT A DRUG DEALER'S HOUSE.
- UH, ADAM...
- NO, NO. NO, NO.
WE KNOW--
I TOLD THEM.
JUST--IT'S IN THE SAFE.
- MM. MM-HMM.
- YEAH, WELL, LET'S...
GET IT OUT, I GUESS,
AND...
LET'S DO ACID.
- ALICE MURPHY, YOU DOG.
[fireworks popping]
[ominous music]
- BYE.
- I ALREADY DID IT.
WAS I SUPPOSED TO WAIT?
- IT'S GOOD.
- YES. FINALLY.
SO WHAT DO YOU GUYS
WANNA DO?
GO OUT TO THE DESERT,
SHOOT SOME FIREWORKS?
STARE AT STARS?
- I HAVE A BETTER IDEA.
[rock music]
- SEE THAT BIG DICK!
LET ME SEE IT!
AAH!
IT'S A BIG DICK.
[giggles]
- SO ARE YOU ENJOYING
YOUR TRIP?
- THIS IS UN-[bleep]-REAL.
IT'S LIKE ALL I CAN HEAR
IS THE SOUNDTRACK FROM DRIVE.
BUT ALL I SEE IS MY MOTHER
RIGHT BEFORE SHE DIED.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN, "DIRGE"?
- YES, OF COURSE
I KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN.
'CAUSE I'M--
I'M TRIPPIN' WITH YOU GUYS.
WE'RE ALL--
WE'RE ALL GONNA TRIP.